Nous sommes au Commissariat
à l'énergie atomique de Saclay
Et voici Gilles Ramstein, paléo-climatologue
Depuis des années avec son équipe,
il met au point des modèles informatiques
qui racontent trois avenirs possibles.
En fait, tout dépend de nous, de la manière dont
nous continuerons ou pas à perturber le climat.
en rejetant du gaz carbonique dans l'atmosphère.
Le 1er scénario est bien sûr utopique :
il suppose que l'humanité, dans sa grande sagesse,
arrête immédiatement les dégâts. Dans ce cas,
le cycle des glaciations se déroule normalement.
La prochaine, comme on peut le voir, commence
dans 50 000 ans pour culminer dans 150 000 ans.
Le 2ème scénario, plus réaliste, imagine
une perturbation du climat importante
mais non massive.
1er constat : la calotte du Groenland supporte
mal cette situation et fond en grande partie.
Et puis on attend, le temps défile et on voit
que rien ne se passe. À 50 000 ans, alors qu'on
doit avoir une poussée glaciaire : absolument
rien. À 150 000 ans, on devrait au paroxysme
glaciaire : absolument rien. Et il faut
attendre 220 000 ans pour qu'une nouvelle
poussée glaciaire commence et qu'elle
augmente jusqu'à atteindre son paroxysme
à peu près 100 000 ans plus tard.
Enfin, 3ème scénario : l'homme ne fait aucun
effort pour limiter les rejets de gaz carbonique
dans l'atmosphère.
Et cette fois, dès le début de la simulation,
le Groenland disparaît.
Mais chose plus extraordinaire encore dans
cette simulation, c'est que pas de poussées
de glaciaires à 50 000 ans, pas plus à 150 000,
rien à 220 000 et en fait rien du tout
sur les 300 000 ans de la simulation.
Vous avez bien compris : les mêmes raisons,
qui ont provoqué le réchauffement climatique
vous éviteront peut être la prochaine glaciation.
Alors on ne sait plus quoi penser.
Faut-il le déplorer ? Faut-il s'en réjouir ?
Après tout, a priori, cela semble
être une bonne nouvelle.
C'est sans doute une très bonne nouvelle
pendant 300 000 ans. Mais pour en arriver là,
il faudra avoir perturbé le système environnemental
tellement fort avec une planète qui comporte.
7 milliards d'hommes que ça sera l'enfer
tout de suite pour un hypothétique bonheur
dans 300 000 ans. Je ne suis pas sûr que
ce soit le bon choix à faire.
Mais nous n'en sommes pas encore là. Pour
l'heure, ne perdons pas de vue que la Terre
est une planète avant d'être notre maison.
Sa logique est celle d'une planète et ce
n'est pas la nôtre.